انسحاب ترامب إذا أردت
من الشرق الأوسط السيد.  لم يبدأ ترامب
ذلك السيد.  لقد واجهنا أوباما
هذا الموقف الغامض والمربك للغاية
للولايات المتحدة منذ
إدارة أوباما السيد.  ربما يكون ترامب
أكثر انحرافًا قليلاً في كيفية تعبيره
عن الأشياء ، لكن علينا أن نقبل
أنه قرر اتباع
مسار عمل في سوريا أعتقد أنه غير
حكيم قال قائد القوات الديمقراطية السورية بقيادة الأكراد
وأقتبس لـ  الولايات المتحدة ، أنت تتركنا
لنذبح ، هل توافق على
موقفه ، فليس لي أن أوافق على
الاختلاف ، لكني ألاحظ أيضًا أن ما
يسمى بالقوات الكردية في شمال سوريا
لم يترددوا في الماضي في التعامل
مع نظام الأسد ، لذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك.
من المدهش أنه بعد أن
تخلت الولايات المتحدة الآن كما تقول عن
أنهم قد يضعون أيديهم في
أيدي نظام الأسد في مواجهة
التوغل التركي ، فإن ذلك يأتي
بنتيجة تمحور الأكراد السوريين
تجاه الأسد ، وبالفعل.
للروس حول سوريا والمنطقة الأوسع
أنا لا أعرف حقًا أن التوغل التركي
لن يجلب السلام
والاستقرار لسوريا كما كان
فشل الروس
والإيرانيين لأي بو.  زعم
أنهم موجودون هناك لصالح
الشعب السوري ، أعتقد أنني لا أعتقد
أن الانتشار لن يأتي إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية في حالة حرب ، إنه
استمرار للشراكة الاستراتيجية
بين المملكة
المتحدة والولايات المتحدة.  للوقوف جنبًا إلى جنب في
أوقات الحاجة وبالتأكيد بعد
الهجوم على منشآت رونكو من قبل إيران ،
كيف يمكن أن يتساوى تصعيد القوات الأمريكية
في المملكة مع الرسالة
من ريو
حول خفض التصعيد مع إيران والتي
تقدم
إيران جيدًا  كن
المقاييس الأفضل لذلك إذا كانوا يريدون
المتاعب ، فالمملكة وحلفاؤها
مستعدون لذلك إذا كانوا يريدون أن
يأتوا وأن يكونوا شريكًا بنّاءً في
تحقيق السلام والأمن ليس فقط
في الخليج ولكن في كل المنطقة من حولنا.
هناك مجال للنقاش حول
رد الفعل على محادثات القناة
مع الإيرانيين أو ينبغي أن نضيف العمل
للتوسط في علاقتها مع إيران في
هذه المرحلة. حسنًا ، لا أعرف أي
تفاعلات عبر القنوات الخلفية  مع إيران
، لم نضرب منشآت النفط الإيرانية ،
ولم نرسل خبراء أو
جنودًا للقتال على الأراضي الإيرانية أو
لقتل الإيرانيين بأي شكل أو طريقة ،
ولذا بالنسبة لنا ، فإن حسن نيتنا ليس هناك
أي علامة على حسن النية على الأرض
من  إيران ما لم يحدث
ذلك ، ولا أعتقد أن المملكة أو أي
دولة أخرى في المنطقة ستتعامل معهم